we're on problem where are we 145
from 145
says
is 1 over p
1 over p
greater than r
over r squared
plus two
that's their question statement number
one i realize i go on these tangents
before even looking at the statement i
should look at the statements first
p is equal to r so let's see if we can
simplify this
so this
this if p is equal to r then we get one
over r instead of a p right
is greater than
r
over r squared plus 2. let's multiply
both sides of this equation by r so then
we know that well
we don't know that r is necessarily
greater than zero
that's the problem
we don't know
because without knowing that r is
greater than or so if r is greater than
zero
what's going to change the inequality
one way or the other so if r let's just
assume r is greater than zero so if we
multiply both sides of this equation by
r then we don't have to switch the
inequality because we're assuming r is
greater than zero
and that's an assumption
then you get one is greater than r
squared over r squared plus two
and then if r is greater than zero then
r squared plus two actually r squared
plus two is always going to be greater
than 0 because r squared is going to be
positive let's multiply both sides of
this equation by r squared plus 2 and
you get r squared plus 2 is greater than
r squared you can subtract r squared
from both sides and you get 2 is greater
than 0 which is true but remember i had
to make this assumption that r is
greater than zero
if you assume that r is less than zero
r is less than zero then all of this is
going to break down because you're going
to get because when you multiply both
sides by r you have to switch the
inequality and you get one is less than
r squared over r squared plus two
and then you'll end up with well
eventually you're going to get end up
with
r squared plus two is less than r
squared or that two is less than zero
which is false
right so this statement alone isn't
enough we have to know whether or not r
is greater than zero
statement two there you go r is i really
should look at both statements first r
is greater than zero so and just so you
know statement two by itself isn't
sufficient because if you know that r is
greater than zero you have no idea of
what p is so you can't answer it yet but
both statements combined are sufficient
to answer this question
next question
is n an integer
and
an
integer
is an integer
statement one says
n squared is an integer n squared
an integer
well that doesn't help us i mean you
know what if n was equal to the square
root of two
and then n squared
would be equal to 2 which is an integer
but this is clearly not an integer
but on the other hand n could be equal
to 2 in which case n squared would be an
integer
so whether or not n squared is an
integer both of these are cases where n
squared are an integer but one ends up
where n is an integer one is where n
isn't an integer so this by itself is
not enough to tell me whether n is an
integer
statement two tells us
statement 2 tells us
square root of n
is an integer
okay so that essentially tells us that
that
n
is equal to some
integer
squared right
i mean you could take the square root of
both sides and get the square root of n
is equal to some integer so you take any
integer you square it you're going to
get an integer so statement two alone is
sufficient to answer this question that
was a strangely easy question they were
getting a little bit hairy and
and confusing but but they've that was a
little bit
that was a nice little rest question i
think 147
if n is a positive integer so n is a
positive integer well n is greater than
zero it's an integer well i didn't write
that down is n to the third minus n n to
the third minus n
divisible
by
four fascinating
fascinating let's see
so
out of my my initial reaction is to see
if i can simplify this as the product of
of simpler expressions because i don't
want to take i look already at statement
number one let me look at statement
number one statement number one says n
is equal to two k
plus one
where k is an integer i don't feel like
taking 2k plus one and cubing it you
know that's you know that's not an easy
thing to do it'll take some time so my
item my intuition is that maybe we
should simplify this a little bit so if
we factor out an n that's equal to n
times n squared
minus 1
and that's equal to
n times what's n squared minus 1 that's
n plus 1
times n minus 1.
and now this is something that's much
easier to substitute this into
so let's do that let's substitute n
equals 2k plus 1 into this
so if n is equal to 2k plus one you get
two k
plus one
times
two k plus one plus one so that's two k
plus two
that's this one and then you have two k
plus one minus one so that's just two k
and then what does that simplify to you
get
2k
plus 1. remember my in the back of my
mind i want it i want a 4 to show up
because i want this thing to be
divisible by 4.
2k plus 1
times
k squared plus 4
k
interesting so now i can factor out a 4
right so it's 2k
plus 1
times k
squared plus k times 4.
and we know that each of these that this
is an integer right because they told us
that k is an integer where k is an
integer we know that this is an integer
because k is an integer and we know 4 is
an integer so we've essentially kind of
factored we factored n cubed minus n and
four is one of its factors
so it's definitely divisible by four i
mean we can divide it by four right now
if we divided by four we'd be left with
this
which is clearly an integer right
because k is an integer so n to the
third minus n is divisible by four if we
can assume that n is equal to two k plus
one where k is some integer
now what do they tell us in statement
two
statement two
statement two tells us
n squared
plus n
is divisible
by six
well i don't see how that's how that's
helpful at all i i don't even
n squared plus n is divisible by 6.
i mean even how do you even you can't
even relate to that to that i mean n
n squared and i could try to do
something fancy or no
but this is just i mean this is so
different than this n squared plus n is
so different from n to the third
there's no i mean i could factor out an
n i could say n times n plus one
is divisible by six well i guess that's
interesting that tells us that this part
is divisible by six
n times n plus one
is divisible by
six
that tells us
well
that tells us that
they do they tell us that n is a
positive integer yeah they do tell us
that n is a positive integer
so this could be two and three
right if this is two and three
then this would be one
right this could be two and three
in fact
well this could be two and three but it
could also be
actually that's the only numbers it
could be it could be two and three in
which case this is one
in which case this whole thing
right n could be if you if you say this
then n could be two
n is equal to two
n plus one is equal to three
n plus one is equal to three and then n
minus one would be equal one and so this
whole expression and let me see is that
the only
case i'm looking at the answer right now
i just wanna make sure they they say
that this isn't sufficient but once
again kind of like problem 142
i actually
because if you say that n is a positive
integer
if you say that n is a positive integer
and that n times n plus 1
is divisible
by 6.
i can't think of any other
numbers where you multiply one number
times the next number and they're
integers where you get a multiple of six
oh well no no i take that back it could
be three and four
right there could be three and four it
could be yeah there's actually a bunch
of them so this it could also be
you know this could be three
this could be four because it's a
multiple of six
and then this would be two so that's
right this is not enough information so
that's good because by this
information n could be 2 n plus 1 could
be 3 in which case this number would be
actually 6 but that still doesn't help
us because 6 isn't divisible by 4 but
then i could come up with a situation
where this number right here where n is
n plus 1 is 4 and n minus 1 is 2 where
it is where this does become divisible
by 4. so this doesn't give us enough
information
not useful
and i'm out of time i'll see in the next
video